let's do this now let's let's jump over
to uh what ted wheeler's been doing
this to me was one of the most
shockingly irresponsible things
anyone could ever say in a position of
government this guy's disgusting
i believe that mayor ted wheeler is
actively trying to incite extreme
violence
death and mayhem agreed he tweeted i kid
you i kid you not he said
this afternoon i was made aware of
concerns within the community
that federal agents may be authorized to
use live ammunition on
demonstrators this evening stop
when people follow or see a retweet they
don't see what follows next they see
that one tweet where he says
they're concerned federal agents may be
authorized to use live ammo
what's the point of that scaring
everybody and what
what do you think a scared person is
going to do
well first blame someone well yeah maybe
i don't know but
if they're intent on going to protest
and they're now terrified that the feds
may use live ammo
but it probably won't go then i don't
think so i think they'll go and i think
they'll bring their own live ammo
ah okay yes so i think he's trying to
get him scared you're gonna get a bunch
of people like oh man i better i better
start packing do
that's the point he wants people to
think this escalation is going to happen
it's basically like implanting the idea
in people's minds
there's going to be live bullets there's
going to be it's going to happen then he
tweets
given the deployment of federal agents
to other american cities and the clear
escalation of the federal government
the information was alarming i have
spoken with the u.s attorney
of oregon billy williams who assures me
that the federal government has no plans
to use live ammunition on portlanders
tonight
and that such an order would be unlawful
nevertheless i am
sharing this information publicly out of
an abundance of caution what
as if they would actually start shooting
these people yeah they're americans
those federal agents inside that
building are americans they're not
trying to kill
other americans who are you ted wheeler
if you play i have some things i'd like
to say to this man
i can't do it on this public's platform
if you plan to demonstrate tonight
please be safe
amazing was he talking to himself
[Laughter]
apparently so he goes out and that was
it for me
because i don't play these games of like
you know
look at a certain point i've talked
about
the attorney general of oregon is suing
on behalf of the pro
of the mob of the of the insurrection so
so hold on
check this out there was a leaked court
it's not leaked it was a court document
that uh showed operation was it called
diligent val
uh diligent valor is that it i don't
know what you're talking about operation
so there's operation legend and diligent
valor right diligent valor
is the the abortac you know the the cbp
deployment to protect federal buildings
legend
is just federal law enforcement of a
normal capacity assisting law
enforcement so like in chicago
they're sending fbi dea atf in into
their normal offices they're there
already
to just assist general law enforcement
so
you have that you have this this uh
document get released
and i kind of lost my train of thought
because i can't i'm thinking about mary
ted wheeler now so i'm going to go back
to that
otherwise i'm going to get angry ted
wheeler
has joined uh uh the protests yeah
this is as far as i'm concerned official
government
joining in engaging in the insurrection
against oh i'm sorry okay i
remember exactly the point i was trying
to make with the diligent vote
yeah the court documents said that the
far left breached
the courthouse on july 4th okay that
these
these people insurrectionists entered
federal jurisdiction and that prompted
the deployment of these officers to the
federal agents to go out and start
clearing things out right they weren't
there until they
broke into the july 4 building right
39th day of writing
and so that was the response if ted
wheeler
stands the police down as police
commissioner which he did if the ag is
suing in defense of the far left
then you have this guy now coming out
the mayor
joining in the riots lying about it
getting tear gassed basically assisting
in
active insurrection against the federal
government yep that's that's how i see
it i
i mean that i'm seeing it too now i want
to show you this this is something that
adam noticed
you wanna you wanna you wanna explain
yeah sure because you mentioned this to
me and i was like no way and
i was like you gotta you gotta prove
this is this true yeah all right so so
last night i was watching i you know i i
really try to get as much
on the ground reporting as i can and uh
last night
there was a lot of people that were
following ted wheeler as he went out to
the protests
so he he the first video people just
start throwing stuff at him dumping
trash right in front of him
yelling at him harassing him and this
this continued the entire time that he's
walking through this
you know but they're they're trying to
interview him he's trying to talk to him
they're like you know are you going to
defund the police
and he's like no not at all and they're
like and then you hear booze everywhere
and then people start screaming
and then you know he's he starts he you
can hear him try to be like yes but
the feds are the ones that are here we
got to be angry at the feds because they
have no right to be here
and you know they start asking and and
they give their demands which is get the
feds out
let all the protesters free pro we'll do
air quotes for protesters
yeah their words not yours protesters
they're their words
um for him to um what is that
what did he say it's it's defund the
police by 50 yeah yeah by 50
release all the rioters yeah they want
uh feds out of portland now and you ted
wheeler must resign
that's right yeah that's that was the
last one so so i'm seeing it they're
interviewing him and he he's
you know he's moving through the crowds
he's trying to speak to them all he's
trying he's clearly trying to be like
i'm on your side
we got to get these feds out and then he
goes over to the barricade in front of
the courthouse
and he he's talking to people and then
you see behind him
the the fireworks well the camera the
borders well that's that's in one video
but
in the ones that i was watching you can
see him standing there watching the
fireworks
go go off over him into the into the
court build a courthouse
yeah you know and i'm like okay so what
is he gonna say like how is he gonna
spin this you know what what's gonna
happen here
and then sure enough the federal agents
come out and start
you know shooting tear gas well the best
part is they say you you when he's doing
an interview in front of the barricades
yeah you hear
you are on federal property you must
disperse
yep and it's like okay okay hold on
you're on federal property ted wheeler
you must disperse right what are you
doing yeah and it's so
you know he's playing it up like it's a
peaceful protest while you can see
people are attacking the building
and throwing commercial grade fireworks
yep and he's standing there and then he
gets tear-gassed
and then he gets interviewed and he's
like man this this tear gas
they have no reason to do any of this i
i i haven't seen anything
all night on why they should be doing
this kind of stuff oh
oh man it's so bad and then the camera
pans
well yeah well i don't know if that's
the same interview but
he is being interviewed and the the
camera pans over from like
you can see the firework mortars going
over the building and then it pans over
to him and he's being interviewed by a
bunch of people
like he's being interviewed and the
camera turns just for some explosions
yeah not from the feds you the funny
thing is the flash bangs the feds use
yeah
are less dangerous than the mortars
probably
flash flashbangs are loud and and and
like
it's a flash and a sound well it's
because that's what it's meant for right
a firework mortar is meant to go explode
and
send fireballs in the air and that's
what it does right so those are actually
really dangerous
but the craziest thing about the night
was uh was was this right here
so so adam comes down and he's like did
you see what happened with ted wheeler
and i was like of course i did like the
dude went out
joined in the whatever you want to call
it they're calling it protests
spare me they've breached the building
more than once and they
are showing up to engage in conflict it
stopped being a protestant they threw
explosives and it stopped being a riot
the moments the moment started breaching
the building to attack
feds right mayor wheeler wants to get
involved in that now you got the
government's official
involvement in insurrection fine
whatever but this is the best part
because adam
he comes down and he's like he's like
you see what happened he's like ted
wheeler
comes out does his his you know potemkin
pr stunt
then goes inside the building and then
the police declare a riot
yep they're not going to declare a riot
while he's out there no it'd make him
look bad
so so so i was like you got we got to
prove this we got to prove this
so adam ended up pulling up these these
tweets from mike baker he's of the new
york times
check us out at 302 am wheeler leaves
the scene
protesters throw water bottles at him
and curse him he manages to get inside a
building after a scuffle between
protesters and a security detail
so you can see here he is right here
he's you know he's getting in the
building
his security guys like shove out the
protesters like get out wait wait but go
go to the beginning of that video real
quick
look keep a little a little bit further
back a little bit further back
look at that mask wearing skill he's got
it on his chin in the middle of this
protest
he's taking it off because he's like you
know camera app's done
i'm going to go inside now don't go to
wear my mask i mean they're filming but
then he puts it up
why someone put a camera in his face
probably or he was itching his face i
don't really
i just wanted to point that out that
silliness it's 302 am
and it goes inside the building and they
push the protesters out
and a half an hour later the portland
police a riot has been declared outside
the justice center dispersed to the
north and or west
disperse immediately failure to adhere
to this order may subject you to the
arrest or
to arrest our citation or riot control
agents including but not limited to tear
gas and or impact weapons wait wait wait
wait wait wait hold on
i thought they weren't allowed to use
tear gas and everyone was saying
the portland police are already not
allowed to use tear gas and it's the
feds who are doing
it as soon as ted wheeler goes inside
that building
yep i say as soon as it was half an hour
half an hour later but
all of this stuff was going on while he
was out there he's the police
commissioner
yes he is you know what i think happened
he went back inside and went and he he
walks back inside
he looks around he goes that's a riot
what are we gonna do
i bet he was scared the entire time man
i i could see it he was trying to keep
his cool but he was scared
he he came back like you can kind of see
it when he gets
shoved into the building the relief
that's on his face like i am
so happy i made it back in here i'm so
happy
let's declare it a riot because it's
getting crazy out there donald
donald trump okay pulled a face down
card from his deck and
and and placed it in front of him with
his with his dual disc on his arm
and then ted wheeler walked up and trump
went ha
he just walked into my trap card it's
the best trap card and then he revealed
it and it was
democrat engages in riot yep and now
trump's going to be like
man there is so much fuel he's gotten
from this
i think they actually had a at one point
they could have really as soon as those
the vans came up and the
and the cops came out and they went with
this narrative unmarked vehicles yeah
that that was that was powerful pr for
the left but they couldn't help
themselves
no they couldn't do it so now trump is
going to come out
as we showed you the the support for
black lives matter is the opposition
tobacco's matter is going up
because of these riots so if people
don't like riots
and trump is saying i'll stop the riots
guess who people will start to support
yeah well and the the clear bias
says who what businesses they were
taking down it's like
they're out there yelling black lives
matter as they're destroying black
businesses
that's just been the case the entire
time i know but i mean and you
saw what can you pull that chart back up
the one that that shows that i like him
yeah yeah so you can see right about
that it's like
george floyd gets killed what's going
down and then support went up because
everybody wanted justice i still do
you know we all do and you know what we
were getting it
they were putting putting forward police
reform bills that actually made sense
but then they they weren't accepting it
they were like no denying it and then
they were started rioting and just
started destroying all these minority
businesses
here's here's what's really interesting
about this graph you can see that over
the past several months
the amount of people that don't that
neither support or oppose was actually
slowly ticking upward
so people were watching this and being
like you know i don't know how i feel
about this
yeah now i gotta clarify that's unsure
is unsure these are people who are
saying
you know they do some good things they
do some bad things yeah so what you were
seeing is opposite opposition was going
down right
and support was slowly going up and they
were actually starting to win
over the opposition if opposition goes
down
and neither supporter pose goes up it
means people that normally were like i
don't i don't like any of that we're now
going
i guess they're okay but i'm not for or
against it really
yeah and then they had to riot and then
whoop inverted
worse than it's ever been right now 13
percent neither support nor opposed
going back to may it was 18. and now
may of last year of last year exactly so
35 oppose it now however to be fair
going back all the way 42
opposed i think trump's seeing this data
he's been seeing it from the get-go and
he's going yep
send in the troops yep send in sending
the cops and in law enforcement we're
going to clean this mess up
i mean people are getting shot every day
people are getting killed little kids
are getting shot and killed
you know atlanta kansas city new york
city chicago
all these these big cities and that's
the important
the important thing is that operation
legend is not
diligent valor that's correct thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 pm if
you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you